we're going to transition to the bottom
half of this page
to see if we can um consolidate and
really wrap our heads around the
big ticket new ideas and there were a
lot of them
that we introduced on friday mornings
it's a big topic right
i get really excited sorry let me start
that sentence again i got really excited
a couple of years ago when the extension
2 course which has not been changed
for like 35 years when we first saw the
draft of it
and this topic the nature of proof the
one that we met last friday
when it was included because it is so
different to every other kind
of mathematics you've been doing and yet
eerily
familiar so what we're going to do is
some of the concepts i introduced
on friday that we had a look at we're
going to kind of dig deeper into them
we're going to formalize some of them
and then see where they go and then
you'll get to
play your hand at doing some more proofs
of your own that are not just ken can
related ones
all right so pick up your pen if you've
got it there and uh let's begin with
well do you remember what is the
building block
of every proof what is the basic unit we
use
it's a statement thank you very much so
these things really are the uh
the alphabet that we are writing this
language of proof with right
now i told you there are um there's at
least one other name that you already
know about
that we sometimes say instead of a
statement we might say that's a
starts with a c that's a claim right
it's like i claim something
to be true that's one other alternative
name but there was other
one other more fancy name one more
technical name that i didn't tell you
just i didn't want to bombard you too
much with language even though i did a
little bit
um the super fancy name for this if you
want to make yourself sound more
intelligent you say oh
that's an interesting proposition right
and what's nice about both of these is
that you can see the verb that's
underneath it
for each one i state that something is
true or i claim or i propose
that something is true right so each
noun comes
with its verb so just as some examples
here right and it's not just because
it's the last period of the day and this
is what i'm thinking of but potentially
you might have these statements p and q
in your head
it's 3 p.m that's a statement right i
claim it is 3 p.m right now i'd be wrong
at this exact moment but i can still
claim it right um the bell will ring
that's another statement okay and you're
going to see we're going to put these
together in lots of different ways
all right so statements they sit on
their own but when you start to put them
together
right when you say one statement leads
to another what did we call that starts
with an eye
thank you very much calvin implication
right
so again uh each of these nouns has a
verb with it so when you see this p
and this double arrow by the way you can
also use or you might see
in textbooks just a single arrow i like
to write the double arrow because it's
kind of like this is quite special
to logic and proof you don't really see
it anywhere else the way i would read
that as i'm looking at a proof is
p implies i'm using the wrong color
implies q okay
now just like with this box with the
statement right we're going to dig into
this a little more and explore some of
the more
different ways of saying the different
language you can use here right
so if p implies q
and if you have a look up above right i
am suggesting that p
it's 3 pm implies q the bell will ring
we can say this in terms of well p it's
it's enough
right it's adequate it will cause q but
we have a fancy word for enough
or adequate starts with an s we would
say it's sufficient
to cause q thank you very much now if
you look at it from the other point of
view right
if you look at it from the the
conclusion from the results point of
view right
q has to result if p happens
and it leads to q then q is a
what's a word that starts with n that
like it has to happen it's you got a
choice about it
it's necessary right q is necessary
given p so we would say p is a
sufficient condition for q
q is a necessary condition for p
now we can also state this in terms of
kind of like if you're reasoning through
this right
p happens it leads to q so if you know
that
the first thing happens it's a necessary
condition
to a sufficient condition as you say to
result in this last one
a nice succinct way to summarize that is
if
one happens then the other will follow
ifp then q and when you see it written
in this particular way implications get
another fancy name because
this thing you can see in quotes there
right if p then
q that is itself a statement
isn't it that can be either true or
false right that's that's anything that
can be true
or false but not both that's a statement
so the kind of statement
that we call it is based on the fact
that well it
it may be true sometimes in other words
if it meets this certain condition so we
call it a
conditional statement hey going so far
brain okay so far we're using words that
are still pretty familiar
right all right let's keep going do you
remember what was the big
next word that we introduced uh that's
when you're talking about trying to flip
around
logic or looking from a different
direction
and for negation thank you
negation as in negative right so
just like in um in integer land right
negation or negative it means the
opposite of something right yes yeah do
you have a question oh yes
i just
yes i'm so glad that you asked that
question in fact it's almost as though
i have a place on my piece of paper that
is anticipating that exact idea
i mentioned there's a symbol for
negation right it's this little step
here it is my preferred symbol but it's
not the only symbol you'll see
you'll also see exactly what jail is
talking about this little wavy line
it's called a tilde by the way that's
out the front it's the prefix
of whatever statement you've got and
they both mean the same thing
i didn't introduce this the first time
because some of you may have seen this
wiggly sign it also means something else
is anyone is anyone else seeing what it
might mean in different contexts
sometimes you see it over the top of
something like this
and that means a vector right um even
earlier than that like in year seven you
would have met this symbol
it's like ah it's approximately equal
like i'm estimating or i'm rounding
right double line
well sometimes you see two sometimes you
see one right so this is what i mean
now i'm putting this here so that if you
ever see this
in the context of logic and proof you
know it means
negation but when i'm writing just
because i want to be as clear and
unambiguous as possible
i'll always use i always prefer this
kind of step
symbol here right so we read both of
them as
the negation of p or more simply
not p okay now as i said up above i've
given you an example of what p could be
it's 3 p.m
we could just put the word not in front
of it but that doesn't make
real good english right so when you have
negations or any other kind of statement
for that matter
interpret the grammar with your brain
okay so in this case if
p is it's 3 pm what would you say is the
negation of p how would you say that in
english
it is not 3 pm that'll do me it's not
3 00 pm those of you who
are um bilingual or multilingual will
know in fact that sometimes other
languages will actually just say no
we'll just put a note at the front
not it's 3pm that's how we say it but in
english
this is what we would say now uh
what we're doing to do now here is put
all the building blocks together right
we're getting
more pieces in our lego kit so you've
got
negations and implications
unsurprisingly you can negate
an implication because an implication is
itself
as we saw above it's a it's kind of a
super statement of like a couple of
statements put together
right so if it is a statement itself you
can negate it right
so here is me using the notation we've
introduced so far do you see this
not p implies q now
how can we try and like unpack what this
actually means i want you to think about
this right
in fact i'm going to get you to turn to
the person next to you in a second to
see if you can turn this into
english and the appropriate symbols
this is p this is q so p implies q
you would say in english as if it's 3 pm
then the bell will ring right that's p
implies q
so what would be the negation of that
think for a second
and then turn to the person next to you
i'm going to give you i'm actually going
to wander around a little bit
how would you say this in english the
negation of p then q
and how would you write it in symbols
take a moment i'm going to wander around
a little bit
i'll admit this is a slightly cruel
question to pose to you
because if we in this room we're just
deciding the rules of logic for
ourselves right you know a lot of maths
is discovered
right it's like it's just out there in
the universe like pi
it's just circles are like that man you
measure across you measure around that's
always the ratio we just
happened upon that but a lot of
mathematics is not discovered
it's invented we just made it up we just
decided it was gonna be this way
right it's like you know what just gonna
start from the positive real axis and go
anti-clockwise right let's just go that
way right
with this we could actually define this
in a bunch of ways but i'm gonna try and
make an argument as to why
some are better than others okay now i
found it really interesting and i know
because i heard some of them
some of you looked at this and you're
like oh brackets
i know what to do with brackets if i if
you saw for example 2
outside of x plus y you'd be like
two x plus two y you know wipe your
hands feel happy
right now let's just think about what
that might mean
for this statement okay let's just let's
just write it okay
if i just distributed the negation
into the brackets right it would look
i'm guessing something like this
do you agree with that that's just me
putting not in front of all the
statements okay
now let's try and turn that into english
and see if it is a meaningful
negation because remember you all wrote
up above but negation means
opposite yeah okay not p implies not
q that means if it's not 3 pm
then the bell will not ring
is that the opposite of p implies q
what are you thinking calvin i'm
interested there's like a a conversation
i want to know what's going on like what
are you thinking oh he thinks
if it's not paid and not here
smart move it's like before i suggest
you know throw in my id
i'm going to throw my friend on the bus
first you know it's like hey this is
what he thinks and it's it's true
this is the point where there's some
ambiguity here right let me suggest to
you
if i said to you it's 3 p.m
that means the bell will ring i think if
we had not introduced any of this fancy
symbol symbols and notation most of you
would have said the opposite of that is
if it's 3 pm the bell won't ring
that's the opposite implication does
that make sense
if it's 3 pm there's the condition right
then the bell will either ring
or it won't that is the most natural
english way to read
the negation how do we turn that
into symbols hmm
well actually i stated p
as it was right it's 3 p.m but what i'm
suggesting is it leads to the opposite
thing this is the negation
of my implication which i know is a bit
weird right let's write it together
in english if it's 3pm
the bell won't ring or then the bell
won't ring
in uh informal
logical language this is actually what
we expect now there is one other way
you could potentially write it but you
got to be a bit careful um you know when
you have an equal sign
if you want to say not equals you have
the equal sign and then what do you do
to it you strike it out right
so you actually can and i'm going to use
it later on on this page i think
you can actually have the implication
and then strike it out
right but it is
clearer and less ambiguous to write it
in this purple way that i've got
over here okay now why is this important
this is super important and this is why
i'm going to argue
that rather than having the not on the p
or the knot on both the p and the q this
is better right
this is a really useful way to logically
disprove something does that make sense
someone comes to you and says
i reckon if it's 3pm then the bell
will ring you're like i don't know can i
prove that that person is wrong
so what you do is you wait until it's
3pm and then if the bell doesn't ring
you have
disproved them does that make sense and
it's easy to do you just wait
for a saturday or a sunday it's 3pm bell
won't ring make sense
so let's just jot that down this is why
this logical piece is so important
it's how you disprove a statement uh
you've been used to proving statements
right but it is just as important
you might remember this with our riddle
of truth tellers and liars right
it is just as important to be able to
disprove something